virgin
no è diventato blu scuro ciao a tutti
bentornati sanità stories
guardate un po cosa mi è arrivato a un
super curiosa di scoprire insieme a voi
perché le paste matite supercar anzi
glitter bomb della cirami allora le
trovate in edicola questa notte ore 50
l'una vediamo un po come nella scatola
allora alcune cambiano colore con il
calore
alcune sono scoppiettanti quindi
immagino smr alcune cambiano colore con
il sole alcune si minore bwv profumate
abbiamo subito ad aprire la scatola mi
raccomando lasciate un bel likes volete
vedere altre recensioni slime altri
video slime ed è un po come cantante
abbiamo poi i magazine o dietro su quel
coretto di vedere come sono perché
sembrano bellissime
allora vediamo nel magazine cos'è certo
il correntista tira mix luna camminare
sull'acqua non gradiva in sono dei quiz
che tipo di persona 6 poi se la lista
come da tanto parlare colorate e dei
fumetti crino allora iniziamo da queste
quattro queste cambiano colore alla luce
del sole quindi prima di abramo le
vediamo e poi li mettiamo al sole e
vediamo come cambiano colore di che
colori diventano sono spesso soprattutto
questa magia di unicorno wow sembrano
bellissime allora questa si chiama
migliore stellare supercar c quindi
iniziamo da questa ok vediamo un po come
questo bagliore stellare
tanto da quanti clijster questo tra
l'altro sono quelle super franci
tiriamola fuori
wow sentite rumori simili rumori non me
lo aspettavo questo brillanti in atto ok
tra l'altro profumo di bubble gum
wow ok ora andiamo aprire le altre poi
andiamo a fargli cambiare colore
prossima se andiamo ad aprile e tocco di
fatta look è bello che fa rosa
ed eccolo qua anche questo scoppietta
tantissimo quota dei rumori pazzeschi e
de rosa con i letterini questo profuma
di fragola forse massimo aurora boreale
[Musica]
wow guardate colore stupendo non ho mai
visto questo colore blu verde acqua con
le palline rosa anche questo scoppietta
tantissimo inquadrate c'è una pallina
blu e mezzo questo profumo di dolce lo
stesso esteticamente è bellissimo e
palermo riba che il prossimo magia di
unicorno siamo super curioso di vedere
questo
[Musica]
che ti amo un po che colore
guardate quanti colori o mio dio
bellissimo allora ha sempre un rosa
chiaro di base con i brillantini e alle
palline di tantissimi colori e stupendo
anche queste super scoppiettante
adesso andiamo a metterli tutti e
quattro al sole e vediamo di che colore
diventano non al sole iniziamo con il
primo vediamo un po è diventato scuro è
diventato blu scuro ma in un attimo
pensavo che bisogna tenerlo un po di più
adesso è diventato blu scuro in un
attimo che bello allora questo rosa
vediamo tanto in tanto
guardate anche questo è diventato scuro
è diventato viola scuro e bellissimo e
super lucido che siete pronti per vedere
quello unicorno oggi è diventato un
viola in un momento
guardate che fico è diventato super
viola scuro
guardate qua è ancora un po bianco e si
sta scorrendo quindi questo è il maggio
di unicorno è diventato viola è
bellissimo anche così
ok proviamo con l'ultimo aurora boreale
cantante
no è diventato blu scuro guardate perché
dietro al rimasto verde
e ora è diventato blu scuro anche dietro
no è fantastico diventano scuri cambiano
colore subito a parte che questo colore
stupendo nei ragazzi ora andiamo a
vedere i quattro glitter gombo che
dovrebbero tutti avere dei glitter
dentro infatti oddio sono super curioso
di vedere anche questi e poi se ne
mancano tanti altri da vedere quindi mi
raccomando non so se avete già preso i
pop corn vi siete già messi comodi come
vi dico sempre questa cosa mi sono
dimenticato del virgolo comunque
mettetevi comodi iniziamo ad aprire i
glitter bomb iniziamo da questo giallo
super glitter hoso si chiama sunshine
glitterball o ci sono tanti glitter
gialli ma non solo sono anche tipo
arancioni dorati
un po come guardate quanti glitter tra
l'altro e tipo mezzo trasparente no cioè
non ci posso credere che come inizia a
fare il video iniziano a fare i lavori
sotto vabbè ignorate i rumori sotto
allora prossimo quindi ma scartare
quindi immagino che ci saranno i cuori e
le stelline dentro questo è una sorta di
rosso ci siamo un po ha tra l'altro c'è
anche scritto rimbalzasti modello non
secca scoppietta aquili dopo proviamo a
farlo rimbalzare glitter bellissimi
wow con questi glitter questi
particolari guardate ci sono correzioni
stelline e altri twitter bellissimo
simili
guardate come brilla anche questo è
morbido estendibile è ovviamente più
piero modellate più sarà morbido alla
fine del video mi potete far sapere qual
è quello che vi è piaciuto di più e vi
dirò anch'io qual è quello che mi è
piaciuto di più ma finora mi stanno
piacendo tantissimo
allora questo è il love and motion
sempre clipper bombe ed è super rosa che
belli questi glitter perché non sono
insoliti glitter hanno anche altre forme
oddio allora questo è un bellissimo rosa
fluo ea dei brillantini rosa arancio è
bello come lo stand di sembra uno smart
trasparente perché il colore non è il
super forte cose si vedono meglio i
brillantini è che l'ultimo che andiamo
ad aprire della serie glitter bombe e il
butterfly power
sembra fantastico questo questo sono
sbaglio e trasparente vediamo
omicidio bellissimo ai brillantini con
le farfalle that per quello schema
butterfly power e anche i fiorellini ed
è trasparente infatti però i brillantini
sono rosa e argentati o meraviglia
bellissimo bellissimo anche questo penso
che della strega heather bown forse
questo è quello che mi piace di più
perché è super bello guerra se tutti
questi glitter bray profumi che andiamo
a vedere sonic ranzi bomb
abbiamo un clean air blue clio il parco
è anche il rainbow un interessante
questo allora iniziamo subito da questo
clima fourball è un profumo buonissimo
e l'effetto trasparente ci sta benissimo
con le palline siamo che andiamo a
vedere dei grandi bomber scrive il corpo
no scusate clearblue
anche questo fa barisoni a smr campi
l'ultimo dei canti bombe e questo crea
rainbows un super curioso di vederlo
perché proposte multicolor che bello
velate quanti colori
[Musica]
anche questo fa tanti suoni
scoppiettanti smr ed è super bello con
questi colori
allora le altre quattro che andiamo a
vedere sono le super canci questo e
cambiano colore abbiamo supertramp il
rosso giallo super g t bird verde acido
supercar anzi nero rosa e super con
silvio la fucsia allora iniziamo da
questo viola fucsia e cambiano colore
con il calore delle mani però io per
velocizzare il processo non lo faccio
vedere con il con un bellissimo viola
opaco con bucci do vediamo un po tumori
fa anche questo fa i suoni super
scoppiettanti sm rt che siamo in fa cose
striscioni e viola con le palline più
chiare tipo rosa chiaro viola ok ora
proviamo con il forno vediamo di che
colore diventa
[Musica]
ed ecco qua ragazzi diventato viola
scuro che figata
poi se avete le mani fredde tipo ma
adesso ho sempre ridiventa dal colore di
prima e fa tipo delle sfumature e
bellissimo ora andiamo a vedere gli
altri colori e il prossimo che andiamo a
vedere e il verde verde acido
[Musica]
alcuni si forma una bolla dentro questo
alle palline tipo sembrano giallo o
verde chiaro siamo i rumori supercar
anzi anche questo wow ragazze diventato
una sorta di verde chiarissimo giallo e
bellissimo anche così vediamo se si
fanno le sfumature
bellissimo anche questo andiamo sedere
ora gli altri vedere ora questo rosso
giallo che immagino che diventerà giallo
vediamo se far rumore bolla anche questo
no
ok eccolo qua è infatti è il rosso con
le palline gialle super super che anzi
anche questo rumor i fantastici
vediamo di che colore diventa indovinate
nei commenti colori diventerà secondo me
diventa giallo
vediamo ok ragazzi è diventato il giallo
era abbastanza prevedibile dal nome
vabbè comunque fighissimo anche questo
con rate la sfumatura uno di quelli che
cambiano colore supercar anzi questo
nero rosa quindi il maggio che diventerà
rosa vediamo quanti clijster a correggio
bellissimo perché ha dei leader verdi
che risaltano tantissimo con il nero
bollente qua ea le palline rosa un che
bello
tra questi super canti cambia il colore
questo è un concreto esempio si diventa
poroso questo è bene sfumature nere
fantastico e che suoni bellissimo allora
ora andiamo a vedere i super car anzi
che si illuminano al buio dopo andrò a
chiudere le tende il tutto così vediamo
anche come si illuminano abbiamo barden
è un torneo nel giallo neon
vediamo subito come sono iniziamo da
questo bird e neon fu anche dei
brillantini e le palline perché un po ed
è davvero un buon profumo tipo di mela i
suoni sono fantastici
allora ora apriamo il giallo neon
transizione l'islam che si illuminano al
buio li fanno verdi c'è sempre visti
verdi quindi sono curioso di vedere
questi gialli e blu come si illuminano
al buio anche questo sai per il
antinomia umana stessa e ananas o melone
anguria
anche questo è super smr l'ultimo è
azzurro neon ti amo
[Musica]
sapete che mi piace un sacco
c'era una bolla vertova allora è un
bellissimo azzurro anche questo super
canzi super smr ok andiamo ora a vedere
come sono al buio ragazzi scusate se non
è super cui eliminano sono bellissimi
perché tipo questo azzurro ancora
ridottissimo capo sul giallo
bene ragazzi sono il tema queste erano
tutte le pazze magiche nuove fasi
un'edicola tre ore e 50 giudizio finale
a me sono piaciute tantissimo e
soprattutto sono diverse ne sono molte
super particolari anche queste clicker
bomb bellissime poi quelli che si fanno
un sacco di rumori e smr quindi mi sono
piaciute un sacco fatemi sapere nei
commenti se a voi sono piaciute quale vi
è piaciuta di più se andrete a comprarle
se le avete già comprato il quale avete
comprato potevi sapere tutto nei
commenti se volete vedere ovviamente
altre recensioni altri video slimer
lasciati un bel like ricordatevi di
iscrivervi e attivare le notifiche
cliccando nella campanellina e io ti
mando un bacione enorme alla prossima
[Musica]